Hi, everyone,
and welcome.
It's Dr. Karen Poole,
and I'm here at
the Jonesboro campus.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about neuroembryology.
So I know that
embryology, famously,
is not the favorite
subject of a lot
of medical students,
and that's OK.
But today's
lecture, I think, is
really going to
lay out the overall
structure of the
nervous system
and how that works in
adults. And I think
that's going to be
helpful. The other
main thing we're going
to talk about here
is when certain steps
in the development
don't go the way we
expect and the congenital
disorders that can
arise from that.
And congenital
disorders in the nervous
system are second only
to heart defects in
terms of frequency.
So these are things
that are going to be
important clinically.
And on that note,
just so you're aware,
we are going to be
talking about some
pretty severe
congenital defects with
fetuses and neonates.
I haven't put a lot of
like graphic images
in here or anything,
but we are going to
talk about things
like anencephaly,
just so you're aware.
Okay,
so our session
objectives here, we're
going to talk about the
timing and the sequence
of events in the
neural tube formation
in a human embryo.
We're going to talk
about cellular
organization of the neural
tube and the neural
crust derivatives.
At the end of this,
you should be able
to compare and
contrast development of
the spinal cord with
that of the brain
and correlate the major
brain developmental
landmarks, that is
to say different
segments of the brain
that we call vesicles
with the anatomy of
the human brain at
birth. And then use
all of that to kind
of think about what
are these most common
neuroanatomical
malformations at birth.
So we're going to
start off with a quick
review of gastrulation.
Okay, remember the
gastrulation is this
step within embryonic
development in which
the three different germ
layers are formed. So
this is when we're forming
ectoderm versus mesoderm
versus endoderm.
And that happens with
sort of the, what
will become ectoderms
or what will become,
you know, endoderm
and mesoderm folding
in from the ectoderm
along this primitive
node and primitive
streak. So here we're
in like a dorsal
view of the embryo
and here we're in a
sagittal cut through
it. So we have the
ectoderm here in blue.
We have that primitive
pit there where cells
are starting to come
inward that will
become the mesoderm
that's shown here in this
sort of pink color. And
part of that mesoderm
will become the
notochord here in black.
And then you have the
yolk *** down here
in yellow, which
will become endoderm.
The details of that
aren't important here.
Just remember, we
have those three germ
layers, ectoderm,
mesoderm, endoderm.
Something else I do
want to note in this
first slide is I'll
have days denoted,
like number of days
into development
that certain
events happen.
Note that I'm
following the typical
embryological convention
here of counting from
fertilization, which is
offset about two weeks
from how we clinically
define pregnancy,
which starts from the
last menstrual cycle.
And so if I say
something happens at 21
days of development,
that's three weeks into
development three weeks
after fertilization,
but that's about five
weeks into clinically
defined pregnancy.
So just FYI if you're
thinking about the
timing of these things.
So now we're looking
at the dorsal
view of the embryo.
So this edge here
is the cut edge of
the amniotic ***.
All right.
And here we see in
blue this thickening
neural plate. So that
starts to form as the
notochord and the paraxial
mesenchyme that is
on either side of that
notochord, as those
start to develop, they
induce the overlying
ectoderm to thicken
into the neural plate.
And that starts at
the rostral end, or
we also call that
the cranial end. All
right, this is what
will become the head.
So it starts at
the head end of the
embryo, and it's going
to move caudally.
And it involves a whole
bunch of signaling
molecules,
Wnts, sonic hedgehog,
bone morphogenic
proteins, all right?
These are all common
signaling molecules
we see in embryology.
I don't care if you
can tell me exactly
which ones are involved
here, all right?
As neuralation continues,
the midline of that
neural plate starts
to fold in on itself,
all right? So if
we have this sort of
flat plate here it
starts to indent
like this and that's
what we're seeing in
this center section
and so that's that
indentation is what
we call the neural
groove and on either
side of it is a
neural crest as those
start those pieces
start to rise up
more dorsally and i
also want to note here
that there's still
a primitive streak
on this embryo. So
gastrulation is still
happening while
nurgulation begins.
So typically, if
we're sequencing
these things, we'd
say gastrulation
happens and then
nurgulation happens,
but there is overlap
between the two.
And then as we continue
with nurgulation,
all right here that
starts really in the
center of the embryo
and then proceeds both
caudally and
cranially but here
if we're looking
at cuts through
a couple
different segments
here's the cut for
line b so here we
have that ectodermin
blue and it's
folding in so we have
our neural groove
here and the neural
crest up here all
right so it's folding
it on itself it's
starting to form this
tube-like structure
that will become
the neural tube.
And at line C here,
that process has
completed. So we
do have this closed
off separated neural
tube, and that is
separate from the
overlying ectoderm.
So that neural tube
is what's going
to form the spinal
cord and the brain,
and the overlying
ectoderm will form
skin, musculature,
and parts of the
vertebrae or skull.
Although in this
case, in the middle
of the embryo,
it'll be vertebrae.
And this is just another
view of that same
process, right? So early
on, we have this sort
of thickened area.
And I wanted to show
this diagram because it
shows that neural plate
nicely. You can see
out here, the ectoderm
are these fairly
small kind of cuboidal
cells. And here, this
is the neural plate
itself, where those
cells are more columnar.
They've thickened. And
that's induced by that
notochord and paraxial
mesoderm along here.
so then that neural
crest comes up wraps
and kind of starts
to cover over that
neural groove we get
the neural tube over
here and here we're
also showing that in
between that surface
ectoderm and the
neural tube we have
a set of cells that
sort of become unattached
in that process
They don't stick to
the neural tube, and
they don't stick to
that surface ectoderm.
They become these
sort of free-floating
neural crest cells,
and those migrate to
a lot of different
places in the body, and
we'll cover those in
some later slides.
So as neurulation
continues, here we're
looking at a dorsal
view of the embryo,
and so here the
neural tube has mostly
closed, but there's
still what we call a
posterior or caudal
neural pore. Alright,
so we have an opening
at the end of the
tube still. And at
the anterior end, we
have an anterior or a
rostral neural pore.
And here we're looking
at it in lateral view.
And you can see
this is happening,
right, 23 to 25 days
into development.
And here the neural
tube is closed off,
completely separated
from that overlying
ectoderm. That
should be about 28
days or four weeks
into development, so
that's about six
weeks of pregnancy.
And then putting that
all together in a
slightly more cartoon
form, we have here in a
slice through the embryo
that notochord with
overlying ectoderm
that starts to induce
the neural plate to
grow. so you have this
thickened area of the
ectoderm that then
starts to fold in forming
that neural groove
as well as the neural
crest and we can see
that in the dorsal
view up here you've got
your neural groove
starting and the neural
folds along the edge
and then you have that
neural tube starting
to form the neural
crust cells that
separate and lie in this
space between the neural
tube and the neural
crust cells. And here
you've got your anterior
or rostral or cranial
neuropore, all
right, and the posterior
or caudal neuropore.
So here's our first of
several different
congenital
disorders. And
in this case,
we're looking
at a failure of
that caudal
neuropore to close.
And that results
in what we call
spina bifida. And
we talked about
this all the way
back in the very
first anatomy lab,
if you remember,
where we talked, we
were talking about the
structure of vertebrae.
And you have here
in this cross section,
your vertebral body.
And then the
pedicles are along the
side here. And here
is the lamina. All
right. And here it's
referring to it is the
the neural arch all
right so if you think
of the whole thing
together as the neural
arch it's incomplete
in this case and that's
because right that's
forming from the
ectoderm that overlies
the neural tube and
if the if that caudal
neural port doesn't
completely close then
the overlying ectoderm
doesn't develop in
the way that it should
so a is showing uh
the the most mild
form of spina bifida
called spina bifida
occulta. You can see that
on the surface the
skin is in place the
way it should be. There
is sometimes, because
of a lack of migration
of those neural
crest cells, you can
get sort of a tuft of
dark colored hair
there, but not always.
And so this is called
occulta because we
often don't even know
about it or don't see
it. And it's found
incidentally when the
patient has scans done
for some other reason.
All right. So this is
a fairly mild form.
If we go to B, this is
called a meningocele
or meningocele,
right? Here, the
meninges are bulging
out. We're lacking those
laminae or the
vertebral arch entirely.
And in this
case, right, we
basically have
a cyst forming,
pushing out
through the skin.
The spinal cord itself
is still where it
should be. There are
generally no neural deficits
with this, but you
do probably want to
surgically repair that
so that there's not
a bulge sticking out
and that *** of CSF,
all right, because
there's potential for
leakage and problems if
that remains in place.
Then we come to
meningomyelocele, which
is also called
myelomeningocele, all
right, either either
sequence works, but
the point is that
we actually have the
spinal cord out in
that membranous ***.
And so here we
have these kind of
displaced lengthened
roots of the spinal
nerves, and so
there can be some
neurological complications
in this case.
The severity will
depend on how high
or low on the spinal
cord this occurs.
And then finally in
the most severe case we
have myeloscesis in
which the spinal cord
itself is open. Like
that spinal cord doesn't
even close. The neural
tube that would lead
to the spinal cord
doesn't close at all.
And so this will have
some neural deficits.
Obviously you've got
just neural tissue lying
on the surface, you've
got to surgically
do something about that
and cover that over.
So this is a complex
sort of problem.
Now, at the other
end, if we look
at a failure
of the rostral
neuropore to close,
and again, going
from sort of least
severe to most,
these collectively are
referred to
encephalocele.
Though technically,
this first thing isn't
an encephalocele.
We also call this
meningocel, all right?
So in this case, again,
you have an opening
in the bones of the
skull, most commonly
in the occipital bone,
and you have the dura
and arachnoid matter
coming out here,
and this fluid CSF
-filled subarachnoid space
that's emerging from
the skull, all right?
So that's also a
meningocel, because
it's the meninges coming
out, forming this
cyst-like structure.
If the brain herniates
out into that
space, then we call it
a meningoencephalocele.
So now we're
truly into the
encephaloceles. This
is brain tissue coming
outside of the true
cranial cavity.
And again, this is
because those skull bones
overlying the brain
didn't fully close.
And then a variation
on that, if part
of the ventricle
comes out into that
space, We would call it a
meningohydroencephalocele
because you also
have some of
this CSF-filled
ventricle inside of
the brain tissue,
inside of the, you know,
also CSF out here.
So you've got
multiple layers of
CSF, brain tissue, CSF.
and the most uh severe
of these rostral
neuroporeclosures
this is the equivalent
of myeloschisis when
we were talking about
spinobifida this
is just a complete
failure of the brain
to form all right so
that's called
anencephaly also called
miroencephaly so the
brain itself does not
form the overlying
bones of the skull don't
ever get induced
to form because the
brain doesn't form
properly and and in this
situation there's
really there's really
not much to do for
that fetus or infant
because they
don't have enough
brain to keep them alive.
So going back to that
neural tube formation,
we already mentioned
those neural
crest cells.
Okay, so once
we've got that
neural tube forming
and the neural crest
cells are basically
going to come from
the very edge of that
neural plate that
formed. All right,
so we've got border
of the neural plate.
These will become
the neural crest
cells. These are
the cells that
don't get attached
either to the
neural tube or to
the overlying skin.
And those will then
migrate to form a
lot of different
structures, both of
the nervous system
and other systems.
So these are important in
that craniofacial
skeleton.
and as part of that
you have the teeth
right because the
maxilla and mandible
are part of that
so it makes sense
these are also
contributing to teeth.
Cranial ganglia
here means some of
the ganglia of the
cranial nerves.
It also contributes
to thyroid
cells continuing
inferiorly.
These neural crest
cells contribute
to the enteric
ganglia and smooth
muscle cells, as
well as parts of
the heart and the
cardiac septa.
They contribute to, or
they really form, right,
the dorsal root
ganglia all throughout
the spinal cord
alongside of it. They're
forming dorsal root
ganglia as well
as the sympathetic
ganglia. So by that
we mean the
paravertebral ganglia, as
well as that celiac,
superior mesenteric,
and inferior
mesenteric ganglion.
And they also contribute
to the adrenal medulla.
And then continuing
in that sacral level,
same thing, enteric and
sympathetic ganglia.
All right. And this
is just a different
view of that
same idea, right?
There's that closure
of the neural tube.
There's those
neural crest cells
splitting off
and migrating
to various parts
of the body.
so a couple other
things that weren't on
that previous slide
these are going to
contribute to the
arachnoid and pia matter
as well as schwann
cells those those
supporting cells within
the neural system
they also form
melanocytes that give
skin and eyes and
hair pigment coloring.
And we mentioned the
facial bones, the teeth,
parts of the larynx
and tracheal cartilage
and parts of the
heart. So problems with
neural crest cells can
manifest in a lot of
different ways that
we're not going to get
into here. But just
know that very often,
you know, you can
see these connections
between some issues
with potentially the
brain, but really like
the craniofacial skeleton,
the larynx, and
the heart, because
those are all being
derived from neural crest
cells. Not the entire
heart, right, but
some of the septum and
valves of the heart.
So once we've got
this neural tube, it
divides into several
layers, all right? So
you have the neural
canal on the inside
of it with a ventricular
layer here, then
a mantle layer, and
a marginal layer.
That neural canal
is going to become
the ventricles of
the brain and the
central canal of
the spinal cord.
The ventricular
layer will become a
thin layer of what
we call ependymal
or glial cells that
that are just lining
the ventricles
and central canal,
the mantle layer
becomes gray matter,
and the marginal layer
becomes white matter.
And then, in
addition to that
sort of concentric
layering within
the tube, we
have a gradient
that forms between
the dorsal portions of
the neural tube and
the ventral portions.
And again, I don't
care that you can tell
me the specific signaling
molecules involved
here, but we have this
gradient that occurs
because sonic hedgehog
proteins are produced
in the notochord on
the ventral side of
the neural tube, and
bone morphogenic proteins
are produced in the
ectoderm that will
become the skin overlying
the neural tube.
And the gradient between
those that's sort
of shown here, right,
grading from this
green into the blue,
that is what creates this
differentiation between
the dorsal portion
of the neural tube
that will be involved
in sensory neurons and
the ventral portion
that will give rise
to the motor neurons.
And if we look at
that in more detail
here, here we have
the neural canal
and this is our very
basic sort of setup.
Here we start to see
what's called a basal
plate and an alar
plate. And those two
are separated by
the sulcus limitons,
right? So that's this
slight divot within
the central canal
that delineates this
more dorsal region
from the more ventral
region all right and
the basal and alar
plates are forming
within that within that
mantle layer sorry
that we saw here so
there's mantle layer,
and that's going to
give rise to the
basal and alar plates.
And then those become
what we are more
familiar with as
the ventral horn
down here and the
dorsal horn within
the spinal cord.
And if we break
that down even
a little further,
we can see
that the sensory
cell bodies,
Remember, those
exist out here in the
dorsal root ganglion,
the cell bodies. And so
those come from the
neural crest cells.
But the axons
will grow into
and connect into
the alar plate.
Whereas for the motor
neurons, they actually
arise from the central
nervous system,
and they grow within
that basal plate that
becomes the ventral
horn of the spinal cord.
So one last point about
the spinal cord is
that in an early
embryo, the spinal cord
is the same length as
the vertebral column.
But the vertebrae
and the somites
around them, so
all the bone and
muscle tissue,
grows at a much
faster rate than
this neural tissue.
And the spinal cord
is pretty firmly
attached to the brain
at its cranial end. so
that means that it
is the caudal end of
the spinal cord that
it's sort of free
hanging here that ends
up moving relative
to the vertebrae so by
24 weeks of development
the end of the
spinal cord the the
conus medullaris which
is labeled here as
the medullary cone
is at about s1 level
by the time of birth,
it's about at L3.
And then in adulthood, it
ends about
between L1 and L2.
So a couple of clinical
notes for that. You
know, if we're trying
to do any kind of
lumbar puncture, epidural
things, you're still
generally safe at
that L4 to L5 level,
even in an infant. All
right, But that is why
we tend to want to be
that low, is just to
make sure in practice
that we're never
going to risk hitting
the spinal cord itself.
And the other thing
here is you can see, for
example, this S1 level
spinal nerve is a
pretty reasonable length
and similar to all
the other spinal nerves
at this stage. But
as that spinal cord
retracts superiorly
through the vertebral
canal, these nerve roots
have to get longer to
compensate. And that's
what ultimately
produces that cauda
equina, that bundle of
these really long spinal
nerves on their way
to get down to the
level where they actually
exit the vertebrae.
Something else to be
aware of here is that
because of all this
and this typical
movement of the spinal
cord, there can be
situations where either
independently or because
of some form of spina
bifida, where the
spinal cord is still
attached to the
surrounding tissue. It
hasn't fully separated.
And in that case,
then instead of this
smooth movement
of the spinal cord
superiorly, you end
up with that spinal
cord being stuck
at a certain point.
And so then all the
neural tissue in
between has to
stretch along with the
growth of the
surrounding tissues.
And that can produce some
neurological problems
and is referred
to as tethered
cord syndrome.
So that's all I have
for this sort of
early portion of
embryology and the spinal
cord. We're going to
be back in another
segment with the
development of the brain.
Hello, everyone,
and welcome back for
part two of our lecture
on the overview of
neuroembryology. And
here we're going to
focus on the development
of the brain.
so we've already
discussed the formation
of the neural tube and
the spinal cord and
the brain like the
spinal cord develops
from that neural tube
it just grows a lot
more than in the spinal
cord now here we're
looking at a sagittal
section through
an embryo at about 28
days of development
So here's that
spinal cord in
blue. And then
here you can see
the ***********
of the brain.
We call this
region rostral
versus caudal back here.
Within the spinal cord,
we could say caudal
this way and then
cranial. But cranial
means towards the
head. So once we're in
the head, we use the
term rostral instead.
Because saying
towards the
head wouldn't
make any sense.
So we have three
primary vesicles within
the brain, that's
the forebrain, the
midbrain, and the
hindbrain. And by
vesicle here, we just
mean like a swelling,
an *********** of
that neural tube.
And so we have
those three primary
vesicles, and they
also have more sort
of formal names
than forebrain,
midbrain, and
hindbrain. and those are
prosencephalon
for the forebrain,
mesencephalon for
the midbrain, and
rhombencephalon
for the hindbrain.
Now, those three primary
vesicles then grow
and divide into five
secondary vesicles. So
the forebrain, or
prosencephalon, gives rise
to the telencephalon
and the diencephalon.
The telencephalon
or telencephalon,
either way, all right,
the telencephalon
divides into the
left and the right
cerebral hemispheres
and this cavity within
it becomes the
lateral ventricles.
The diencephalon
gives rise to the
thalamus, the
hypothalamus, the optic
nerves and really
the eye forms as an
outgrowth of it and
the space that cavity
inside becomes the
third ventricle.
Also it took me an
embarrassingly long
time to realize this
so I'm just going
to tell you all. The
lateral ventricles
are ventricles one
and two because
there's a left and
a right. That's
why the third
ventricle is the third.
The midbrain,
the mesencephalon or
mesencephalon remains
the mesencephalon and
the midbrain. That's
all it's called. It
doesn't divide, so that
one's easy, and the
space within it is
called the aqueduct or
the cerebral aqueduct.
The hindbrain or
rhombencephalon divides
into the
metencephalon and the
myelencephalon. The
metencephalon becomes
the pons and the
cerebellum. So you always
want to associate
the pons and the
cerebellum with
each other. They're
forming from the same
level of the brain.
And then the
myelencephalon
becomes the medulla.
and this the cavity
within all of
those leads to the
fourth ventricle
so i want to make a
note here about sort of
the folding of the
brain as it develops
and how that relates
to the ways we refer to
directions in the
brain because it is a
little odd all right
so early on this is
actually initially at
some point pretty much
straight but rostral
is always going to be
this direction within
the brain, and caudal
is this direction
towards the spinal cord.
But as the brain grows
and sort of folds
over itself, as we
see here by six weeks,
rostral becomes almost
90 degrees to caudal,
but we keep referring
to these directions,
even in adult
anatomy in the brain.
So within the brain stem,
caudal is more or
less in an adult
inferior and rostral
is more or less
superior. But then
as we move into the
diencephalon and
telencephalon, then rostral
really means more
like anterior
anatomically and caudal
is more posterior.
So there's this bend
in the brain that makes
that directionality a
little bit confusing
so I just wanted to
address that here.
And then here are
the adult derivatives
of the forebrain,
midbrain, and hindbrain
and their different
components with
the added information
of the cranial
nerves associated with
each here. All right,
so the olfactory
nerve comes from the
telencephalon, the
optic nerve, as I
mentioned, the optic
nerve and sort of
the outgrowth of that,
which is the eye,
comes from the
diencephalon.
The midbrain or
mesencephalon has
the oculomotor and
trochlear nerves.
And then here, the graph
isn't exactly divided,
but the pons gives
rise to the next four
cranial nerves. So
that's 5, 6, 7, and
8. So we should put
a line across here.
That all goes with the
metencephalon, or pons.
And then coming
from the medulla,
we have the last
four cranial
nerves, 9, 10,
11, and 12.
This table actually
doesn't list 11 because
it's the spinal accessory
nerve, most of its
nucleus really is down
in the spinal cord,
so it doesn't
list it here with
the medulla, but
it is along there.
So our last four
are medulla.
So we have a congenital
disorder associated
with sort of this
step in the process,
and that division of
the prosencephalon
down the midline.
So really it's
the lateralization of
both the telencephalon
and diencephalon
that are involved
here. And
holoprosencephaly means one
prosencephalon or a
whole prosencephalon,
so it's not divided
along the midlines.
This means there are
not separate left and
right cerebral hemispheres,
and there are not
separate lateral
ventricles. They are in
communication with
each other, typically.
So if we look at that
in MRI form, here is
a T2 MRI from a two
-year-old girl, and in T2
MRIs, CSF is going to
show up really bright.
All right, so this
bright area here are the
two lateral ventricles,
which are one large
ventricle in this case.
They are communicating
across that midline,
so there would be
probably at least somewhat
a lack of a corpus
callosum in this
situation. And here you
can see there's a bit of
a longitudinal fissure,
that division between
the left and the
right cerebral hemispheres
in this case, or
sorry, posteriorly, there's
a bit of a longitudinal
fissure, but anteriorly
there is not.
So this would be
considered a more
mild case, all
right, and there's
still definitely
some neurological
problems associated
with that. There
can be seizures,
motor impairments,
hydrocephalus, which
we'll talk about
later, which is
sort of impaired
flow of cerebrospinal
fluid. Now there
can be hormone
dysregulation because
the hypothalamus
can be affected.
So even milder
cases are going to
have a lot of
neurological problems.
More severe
cases of this,
though, lead to
basically because
you don't have
lateralization
and a left and right
division of those
cerebral hemispheres,
then you also
don't really get
lateralization of
the facial features
that overlie them.
So you can have
cyclopia, like a single
midline eye instead
of two eyes, this
sort of tube-like
or proboscis-like
nose that's with a
single nostril, problems
with the lips and
palate not forming
properly. So there's
a lot of facial
abnormalities that
happen with this.
And, you know,
severe cases of
holoprosencephaly are
likely to be stillborn,
and they have a high
mortality within
the first month
and year of life.
All right,
so now we're going to
kind of go through each
level of that brainstem
and talk about the
distinctions there,
but I just want to
review the spinal cord
in relation to it. So up
here we have the early
brainstem versus the
early spinal cord,
and we've already seen
similar diagrams to
this, right, where we
have that alar plate
and the basal plate, and
they're divided by that
sulcus limitans all
right we didn't talk
about as much the floor
plate and the roof
plate here but that's
just these this
layer of ependymol or
neuroepithelial cells lining
that central canal and
that roof plate is
going to play a major
role in the the formation
of the brain stem.
Now in the early
brain stem it's
pretty similar except
that this central
area that will
become the ventricles
is much larger
than what becomes
the central canal
in the spinal cord.
And we still have
an alar plate which
will give rise to
sensory regions and a
basal plate that will
give rise to motor
regions. But these
arrows sort of indicate
the growth that's
going to happen here.
And here in the
midbrain, as one example,
and this is probably
the most similar region
to the spinal cord,
even though there's a
bunch of extra stuff
happening, we still have
this sensory region
that is more dorsal
and this motor region
that is more ventral.
now if we look at
the myelencephalon
specifically
here and here
we're looking
at a dorsal view
and we sort of cut
through what will become
the fourth ventricle
here which is the
roof plate and we're
looking at a dorsal
view the important
thing here are these
cross sections and
you can And you can
see that roof plate
has grown dramatically
in this region.
So that we end
up with alar
plates that are
more lateral
and basal plates that
are more medial. So
instead of this dorsal
ventral divide, we
actually have a sort of
lateral to medial divide
because we've gone
from a tube like this
to something that's more
open with a roof plate
connecting my fingertips
here. all right
so our sensory regions
have moved out to
the sides and the motor
regions remain more
or less where they
were but now that seems
more more medial than
ventral as compared
to where the sensory
regions are and we
can break that down
into where the visceral
afferents are special
visceral afferent
general visceral
afferent all of that okay
and I'm not going to
go through each of
those, but they're on
the diagram for you.
And here, this is very
similar to what we
just looked at, but I
did want to contrast
the upper or rostral
portion of the medulla
here with the lower
or caudal portion.
So in the lower portion
of the medulla, it
looks a lot more like
the spinal cord, all
right? It doesn't
really have like those
dorsal and ventral horns,
so it's not exactly
the same but we do have
more or less a central
canal here and then
sensory areas sensory
nuclei that are more
dorsal and down here
the pyramids are they're
not motor nerve or
they're not motor neuron
bodies but they are
axons for the motor
system coming from the
cortex ultimately
and then down to the
spinal cord. All right,
so those pyramids are
a motor region. And so
we have that sensory
dorsal versus motor
ventral dichotomy here.
Whereas in the
rostral portion of the
medulla, those
sensory regions have
moved out laterally,
or if you like
alliteration, they
are to the side.
So sensory side,
motor, medial here.
moving into the
metencephalon
and there's a i
know there's a lot
going on in these
diagrams but
here we're looking
at a lateral
view of the whole
brain here's
our forebrain
up here midbrain
here's our developing
metencephalon and in
sort of a sagittal
section through there you
can see that part of
that is the cerebellum
part of that is the
pons and then what will
become the fourth
ventricle is in between.
And then here we're
looking at a cross
-section through there
and there we can see
once again we've got
this fourth ventricle
forming that roof
plate or a pendimal
roof forming and this
region with the yellow
arrow going to it
is what we call the
rhombic lip and that's
what's going to give
rise to specifically
the vermis of the
cerebellum, and this
whole sort of dark
blue region will give
rise to cerebellum.
So that's
ultimately going
to sort of wrap
back around
to this region behind
that fourth ventricle.
And then here, this
is a similar view to
this, just later in
development, where we can
see that cerebellum
has grown dramatically.
So if that
doesn't happen,
specifically the vermis
of the cerebellum
grows from that
rhombic lip.
And sometimes that
doesn't happen properly.
Again, it's very
multifactorial. It can
happen for all kinds
of different reasons.
but if that happens
then you end up with
either agenesis or
hypoplasia of the cerebellar
vermis and that's
indicated here in the with
the yellow arrow on
this normal MRI it's
this whole region here
this is all cerebellum
and you can see here
this is what the fourth
ventricle should look
like right you You
get this nice sort of
triangular shape here.
But over here, because
the vermis did not
develop, you have
this huge area of
cerebrospinal fluid here
that is this sort of
large cystic region of
the fourth ventricle.
And we only have a
very small part of that
cerebellar vermis, and
often what happens is
that ends up sort of
pushing upwards and this
ventricular system
doesn't communicate
that well. So you can
often get hydrocephalus
associated with Dandy
-Walker syndrome. Now
the primary problem with
Dandy-Walker is because
that cerebellar vermis
doesn't develop,
you have ataxia. So
problems with coordination
and particularly
an unsteady gait.
And as I said, but
it can often be
associated with
hydrocephalus,
which we'll cover
in a later slide.
Moving up to the
mesencephalon,
here, again,
we're looking at
that lateral view
of the brain,
forebrain up here,
we're looking
at a section through
the midbrain.
And once again,
we have that alar
and basal plate,
giving rise to
various portions
of the midbrain.
and then as we move
here into the 11th week
of development as
that telencephalon
increases in size here
we've got a couple
different sections through
here so we're looking
at the inferior
midbrain here and the
more superior portion
here we have the
superior colliculus and
the inferior colliculus
and those are somewhat
sensory in nature
right and you can see
those basically have
have come off from
that alar plate and
then down here depending
on the level you have
either the trochlear
nucleus or the
oculomotor nucleus and
those are motor so once
again we have that
sensory versus motor
dichotomy and then the
aqueduct the cerebral
aqueduct is right in
the center of that.
So now we're going to
talk about the overall
growth of both the
cerebrum and the
cerebellum. So remember
this division here if
we're looking at the
general tube, the general
neural tube structure,
you have this
ventricular layer lining
the neural canal, a mantle
layer that becomes
gray matter, and a
marginal layer that
becomes white matter. All
right, and that's
reflected up here again.
Here they're calling
the ventricular
layer the
neuroepithelial layer
and then mantle
and then marginal.
And in the spinal
cord things stay
that way, all right?
So you end up with
gray matter surrounded
by white matter
tracts, surrounded
by pia matter.
In the cerebrum and
cerebellum though, these
neuroblasts that will
ultimately give rise
to neurons, they start
to migrate outwards.
All right, so here we
have the cerebellar
view, and we have these
migrating neuroblasts
coming out here,
forming these different
layers of the
cerebellar cortex. And
then down here, we have
the cerebrum. So again,
you have migrating
neuroblasts coming out
here and forming this
primordial cortex.
So the key thing here
is that this is how
we end up with gray
matter on the external
surface of the cerebrum
and the cerebellum
whereas in the spinal
cord it's simple
uh gray matter
surrounded by white
matter tracts here
we have migration of
neuroblasts that go to
the outside and carry
gray matter
out there more
more towards the exterior
and I won't get into
all the different
layers but that's
essentially how those layers
are formed all right
so here we're looking
at neocortex in the
parietal in blue
and frontal lobes in
pink all right and that's
neocortex and then
remember that there's
also allocortex or
paleocortex which is
simpler. It's only
three layers as opposed
to six, and that's
going to be found on
more the ventral sides
of the cerebrum, the
olfactory regions,
and the hippocampus.
So fetal development
is mostly just a lot of
that happening,
right? You have those
neuroblasts migrating
and producing neurons and
increasing the size of
the cerebrum. So the
cerebrum starts off
fairly smooth but those
gyri and sulci develop
through the fetal
period and as the cerebral
hemispheres grow they
cover the diencephalon.
So here you can
still see diencephalon
a bit and then it's
covered by week 26 here
by the occipital lobe.
And as we continue,
the insular cortex
is still visible
externally, or laterally,
I guess we could say,
for quite some time.
It's still visible
here at week 30.
But by week 38,
sort of the end of
fetal development,
that is covered
over by the
temporal lobe. And
you can see these gyri
and sulci continuing
to develop.
so if that fails
to occur or or or
occurs slowly we call
that microcephaly so
microcephaly is
just a reduction in
that neurogenesis
so hypoplasia of the
cerebral hemispheres
and the overlying
cranial bones,
because the brain
essentially
forces those bones
to grow to
accommodate the brain.
And this, like many
other things we're
looking at here, has
multiple causes. It
can be genetic. It can
be due to infection
during pregnancy,
exposure to alcohol,
exposure to radiation.
So this is a
multifaceted thing.
Lots of things
can cause it.
And it will have
varying degrees of
neurological issues
depending on the extent.
So I want to wrap
up by talking about
the development
of the ventricles,
which we've
already touched on
here, but I've just
got a few images
to really pad that
out, all right? So here
we're looking at a
schematic view where
we see the telencephalon
dividing into the
cerebral hemispheres
and inside of that
there are these two
lateral ventricles and
they have a huge amount
of choroid plexus
that's the cells that
produce cerebrospinal
fluid all right and
they will initially
are in communication
with each other but
as the cerebral
hemispheres divide they'll
be cut off from each
other but each will
still communicate with
the third ventricle
between the parts
of the diencephalon
and that then
communicates with the
aqueduct that goes
through the midbrain
which connects to the
fourth ventricle in
the hindbrain or
rhombencephalon and the
fourth ventricle then
has openings into
the subarachnoid space
and so that's how all
of this cerebrospinal
fluid which is
produced in these
various choroid plexuses
flows through the
ventricular system and
then from the fourth
ventricle out into the
subarachnoid space
outside of the brain,
where it then gets
reabsorbed through the
arachnoid granules
into the venous system.
And there is also
a connection from
that fourth
ventricle into the
central canal of
the spinal cord.
And then here, it's
kind of just a rehash
of that, right?
you have your third
ventricle in the
diencephalon and then here
in sectional view
and that connects to
each lateral ventricle
as that roof of the
third ventricle sort
of divides the two
lateral ventricles from
each other and each
lateral ventricle
is connected to the
third ventricle via
the interventricular
foramen also called
the foramen of munro
then here we're
looking at sections at
two different points
in development through
here so basically
a coronal section
through the brain
and here you can see
each lateral ventricle
and they're now
being divided from
each other here by that
ependimal roof of
the third ventricle
and here you can see that
interventricular foramen
and the thalamus
on either
side of the
third ventricle
and then by here
you can see sort of
that full division
now there are still
interventricular foramina
that will connect
the lateral to the
third ventricles
but they've gotten
smaller at this point
they're just a small
foramina and you
can only see through
a particular slice
and so here's sort
of our general setup
in the end and you
can see that there's
choroid plexus
growing into each of
the ventricles each
lateral ventricle and
the third ventricle
all have choroid
plexus and so does
the fourth ventricle
and that lateral
ventricle grows along with
the cerebrum so it's
the white space here
inside the cerebrum
and as the cerebral
hemispheres grow that
lateral ventricle sort
of grows different horns
here. So we have that
temporal horn going
out into the temporal
lobe, and then lastly
the occipital horn
going out into the
occipital lobe develops.
So here's our
final setup of the
ventricles sort of
ghosted within the
brain here. So
this is all lateral
ventricle and the
occipital horn back here.
There's that
interventricular foramen
connecting to the
third ventricle here,
wrapping around
the interthalamic
adhesion, which is
that little circle.
Then CSF will flow
through the aqueduct
in the midbrain down
to the fourth ventricle
in the hindbrain
and from the fourth
ventricle either into
the central canal
of the spinal cord
or exiting through
various openings into
the subarachnoid space,
which will then wrap
around the brain.
So our last disorder
is hydrocephalus,
and that is, and I
mean you'll see that
come up in a lot of
contexts in medicine,
congenital hydrocephalus
is typically what
we call non-communicating.
So it just means
that there's a blockage
somewhere in the
ventricular system,
and cerebrospinal fluid
cannot do what I just
described, and flow
from the lateral to
the third ventricle
through the aqueduct,
into the fourth ventricle,
and then into the
subarachnoid space.
So if cerebrospinal
fluid can't drain
properly, it builds up
within those ventricles,
and those push
outward on the brain,
and the brain pushes
outward on the skull,
and everything gets
sort of enlarged
here. So signs of this
include large head
size, and particularly
also you'll see
bulging veins, and
remember that in infants,
the bones of the
calvarium are not all
sutured together, and
there are membranous
portions there called
fontanelles, and
so those fontanelles
will bulge outward.
And in terms of symptoms,
right, general sort of
irritability, drowsiness,
vomiting seizures,
that kind of thing is
what you're going to
see with hydrocephalus.
So summing it all
up, remember that
the nervous system
develops from
ectoderm, and the
process of forming the
neural tube is
called neurulation.
Neural crest cells
then migrate from the
neural tube to form
parts of the peripheral
nervous system as well
as other structures.
Once that neural
tube is formed, it's
divided into basal
plates and alar plates.
The basal plates
are associated with
motor regions and the
alar plates with sensory
regions. The final
configuration
differs a bit between
the spinal cord and
the brain stem, so look
at those differences
to think about the
differentiation
between motor regions
and sensory regions.
And then finally, the
brain is formed by a
series of vesicles,
each of which is sort
of an inflated area
of the tube, and each
vesicle gives rise to
a portion of the brain
and a portion of the
ventricular system.
And finally, as
a summary slide,
I have all the
disorders that
are listed in
this lecture,
and the embryonic
structure that is affected,
and sort of general
description of the
result of that
embryonic structure not
developing properly. I
have not listed all the
symptoms associated
with each of these.
That might be a good
exercise for you to do.
But that's all that
I have for you today,
so I hope that you've
enjoyed this lecture,
but if you haven't,
either way, I appreciate
feedback, and I wish
you happy studying.